yo what's up samuel leeds here i'm a
property investor i've been investing in
property now for over a decade
12 years and in this video i wanted to
share
the one biggest mistake that i've made
in property
over and over and over again honestly i
went through
my spreadsheets and properties looked at
the numbers
and just saw when things went wrong and
every single time someone went wrong
it boiled down to the same thing sorry
it's so hot
sorry i'm sweaty it's like i don't know
how hot it is probably 30 degrees
absolutely roasting but i have to do a
video i had to get this off my chest
i've been looking at my spreadsheets
today and this is the thing i'm just
going to hit it right out with
you right now then i'm going to explain
the thing all boils down to people
because here's the thing property
business
is not a property business it's a people
business
if you think money comes from property
then you're stupid
you're financially illiterate because
money doesn't come from property money
comes from people now you might think
you have a samuel what happens if the
house doesn't go up in value though
that's nothing to do with a person
that's something to do with
a property the property didn't go up in
value but here's the thing
who determines whether the property went
up in value or not
the answer is a person a
buyer a house is only worth what
someone's prepared
to pay for it so it comes from people
so let me give you some examples i'll
say i'll say
i'm going to see how this house performs
i hear a lot of investors say this
let's just see how this house performs
what does that mean
that means let's see how the house
performs the thing is that's such a
stupid thing to say because
if you if you have that mentality of
let's just see
how this house performs it's probably
not going to perform that great
because a house will perform what is
performing before means
how well will it rent out what's the
cash flow going to be each month
and who is responsible for how well that
house performs
and the answer is a person because
money comes from people property
business is a people business
and who is that person it's probably not
you is probably the latin agent
but if you if you have a relationship
that's not great with a lane agent
you've not met them you've got no
rapport they don't like you
they don't know you they don't trust you
what's going to happen is the letting
agent is going to not prioritize
well i'm not i'm even holding this phone
ups knackering my arm out
i hope you guys are enjoying this video
by the way if you enjoyed it smash the
like button
that really helps me out a lot i do a
video every single day on youtube
even in the sweltering heat the sweat
drink cold
whatever the weather it's all good i'm
doing a video sharing my property
journey with you
i just been on a run as well i am
roasting hot but here's the thing
right now my property business is making
money why
because i've got good people running the
business
if a lane agent oh by the way i'm
walking uphill right now as well it
might not look like it
i am that's an excuse for i'm so badly
out of breath
if a laying agent doesn't like you that
much
what's going to happen is they're going
to prioritize other people's houses
because they're going to prioritize the
houses of the landlord who they want to
impress and they want to please the most
now you might think i need to breathe
down their neck then i need to chase
them now you don't
you need them to want to rent your house
out
and in the same way when you're dealing
with staff you don't beat them with a
stick
you lead them with love let's see how
the house performs no
let's find a good letting agent let's
manage them well
and let them manage the properties and
it's going to give us the best chances
of making sure that we it performs well
next you know let's hope it values up
you can you can
you can control that if you want the
property to value up
find out what people want do people want
an extra bedroom get an extra bedroom
push the value up that way
and if you're getting a valuation who's
going to be the valuer believe it or not
a person my biggest mistake i'm just i'm
just leaving it to fate
leaving it to the property professional
gods to make the decisions
now i realize i can jump on the phone
now i've realized i can go out and i can
meet the valuer
in person this business is not about
b to b or b to c this is h to h
what i'm talking about is people say are
you b to b or you beat to c or you yeah
that means that you business to customer
or business to business
i'm person to person i'm a person i'm a
property investor
by the way my my net worth on my
property portfolio
and across my property businesses i'm
doing pretty well
so i got i've got my net worth made i'm
going to publish it real soon but it's
considerably
more than 10 million i'm 29 years old
and i'm giving you this information
based on experience i'm giving this is
not me after i read a book okay
believe it or not most of the books that
you read are written from people who
don't know what they're talking about
you know you think who's this author
that wrote this book they wrote a book
it must be true
actually no it's a part of nonsense
they'll be talking about
b2b and b to c and i'm talking about h
to h
i'm realizing that you got bad builders
man it was the builders that cost me a
load of money
yeah h to h you didn't manage the person
who chose to build us it's a people
business
the builders it was a joint venture
partner you know
they screwed me over well did you choose
them
did you manage with them did you manage
them well i mean geez
take responsibility remember this
business is a people business
that's my biggest mistake and as i said
i can look through i can look through
all of my properties that have gone
wrong and every time
it's gone wrong because of a person
because someone did something wrong
because the mortgage the mortgage lender
didn't give me their whatever a
redemption statement on time and it
messed me up and it meant i couldn't end
up selling the property on time and
yada yada yada i'm going to hear my
staff talking like this because
you know i've just had this today by the
way
just had this today oh no the mortgage
lenders refusing refusing to give you
the statement it's not happening
you know we're not gonna be able to do
this i guess what i jump on i pick up
the phone
and within three minutes is sorted and
they're like oh but your staff was
saying they were going to complain
you're going to be planning on distorted
why is it sorted it's not sorted because
i am anything special or they're like oh
my gosh and some of your leads no
they haven't heard of that it's not to
do with that the reason it's sorted
is because i've learned that property
business is a people business
and i've learned to master the art of
not only the number crunching
and the bricks and mortar sides of the
business but i've learned to master the
people side of the business
you might be watching this video now
thinking what are you talking about
you're just
shouting down an iphone you've not met
but i'll tell you something
when i'm when i'm doing business when
i'm doing property business i know
how to create a deal and i know how to
get the best down people
that's why i wrote two property books i
wrote one book called buy low rent high
buy low rent high is all about property
it's great it's a good book it sold
over 100 000 copies best seller on
amazon it's a good book
wrote that 2016. need to uh you
definitely need to read that
but then i went and did a financial
freedom challenge where i started all
over again from
scratch i became financially free in a
week and everyone was saying how did you
do it how did you do it how did you
start all over again
lock yourself off from your bank and
become financially free and the answer
is when i was thinking geez how did i do
it
and i wrote a little book called seven
days to financial freedom
now i'm not suggesting that you're gonna
be able to become financially free in
seven days
i'm just saying what i did i became
financially free for the second time
first time took me four years second
time took me seven days
and when i wrote the book seven days to
financial freedom
what i realized was that it was actually
a people book
this book was about people and
everything in the book it was about how
to negotiate with sellers
how to find investors how to sell deals
it's all about people
you gotta master the people business so
i don't even know where i am actually
now i'm lost
i'm near my house somewhere in
buckinghamshire but i'm lost but i hope
you enjoyed the video
get get get understand how to deal with
people
and i'll tell you something when you
know how to deal with people
and you realize that the property
business is actually a people business
suddenly gets a whole lot easier that's
my biggest mistake my biggest mistake is
forgetting there's a people business
letting someone else do it i just let
the letting agent deal with that because
that's their job i'm not getting
involved
i'm just gonna let i'm just gonna let
the builders deal with that that's what
i'm paying them for
i'm paying the project manager to deal
with that i don't need to get involved
with that
no no no no you've got to take
responsibility choose the right people
and then make sure that it happens
it's a people business it's a people
business that's when you get bad tenants
oh i've got a bad tenant it's not my
fault they're letting agent messed up
yeah but who chose the latin agent you
chose the letting agent
find the right people manage people
people business my biggest mistake my
biggest problems have always come
from when i forgot
this this really important lesson so
comment below your thoughts if you
enjoyed the video smash the like button
i want to see the blue thumb poking up
that really helps me out i appreciate
when you do that
also share the video around drop a
comment
and uh if you're not subscribed already
subscribe turn the notification bell on
and i'm going to find my way home as i
say i'm lost a bunch of sheep around
look at that
you see these sheep pretty tame [ __ ] but
anyway guys i'll see you tomorrow thanks
for watching
peace out